so the app that captured the imagination
of millions of puzzle funds let's talk
about that now is being sold or has been
sold in the new york times
it's of course wordle a simple idea
working out a word through sheer logic
and a little bit of luck
so why has it gone down such a storm
let's find out with somebody who is a
word guru and lexicographer susie dent
it's great to see you again susie thank
you for joining us on the programme this
morning
why is it such a hit
lots of reasons i think okay but um
first and foremost i think it's the
comfort factor you know and uh let's
face it uh the world around us is
slightly messy at the moment i think we
can just find a little oasis in a really
simple joyful word game its rules are
very simple uh we are set the same
challenge
as everybody right across the world
every day
and there's only one we're rationed to
one so i think it's teaching us the
level of patience that you know hasn't
been required of us really for for years
because there are so many apps out there
obviously that offer endless plays of
things so i think it's really special
from that point of view
what are your top tips
well i know people assume that i'm going
to be a real strategist about this and
there are a lot of people who try and
work out algorithms and things but to be
honest i just um dive straight in
there's probably a little bit of um
of kind of i don't know bargaining i
suppose on my part in that i will go
with one of the most frequently used
letters e always because that's at the
top of the list and i often start with
noise because that includes some of the
most frequently used letters as well um
so you can if you like approach it from
that point of view
but for me the kind of the real pleasure
is in the process of elimination and
that code breaking exercise that comes
after so
you know there's no time pressure as
well you can ponder it all day if you
like and as long as you obey the golden
rule and do not put any spoilers on
twitter or social media because that can
genuinely ruin someone's day
yeah it's not fair i always start with a
jerk because it's got quite a lot of
values apart from oh in there hasn't it
it reminds me of must you won't remember
mastermind but when you just have to
play with you're not old enough don't be
ridiculous
yes it's exactly like that as i say it's
a process of elimination and i just love
the fact that we're all doing the same
thing um and you know i can't i think
none of us could begrudge josh morton
for um wanting a reward from this and
also i think from his statement and from
everything he said so far you know it
seems like it was almost becoming too
much for him it's not something he he
expected um and to be fair the new york
times also has real pedigree when it
comes to um word games obviously it has
its crossword um as well which is very
famous so
you know hopefully uh they say that it
will initially be free hopefully that
initial period will uh you know will be
a long one and we can all keep enjoying
it be as much as almost as popular
almost as popular as your word of the
day on twitter what's the word today
i haven't decided yet actually quite
often they are quite self-referential
and i i know that i often bounce off
topical events as well but um yes i
think um i've done wordle for today
that's my first challenge and i will let
everything else percolate and then have
to think about what i'm going to post
today
looking forward to it thank you